[Musique]
les polars elles sont presque toutes
récolté au domaine de dunham et elles
ont rempli le quart des cas seulement
normalement son tient pas compte déjà
beaucoup plus on a de fait 80 et puis
voyez où se tenir le 21
avec le gel du printemps de nombreux
bourgeons sont morts ou ont donné des
fruits difforme puis la chaleur s'est
installée plus tôt et dure plus
longtemps que d'habitude la chaleur est
intense ça ne fait pas loger les fruits
c'est le froid qui favorise les fruits
mais les fruits continuent à mener quand
même alors ce qui se passe c'est qu'à un
moment donné le feu lui a atteint sa
maturité pour l'entreposage mais il n'y
a pas la couleur donc ils vont être
rejetés au tri
les vergers doivent aussi composer avec
un manque de pluie qu'il ne plus
compenser par l'irrigation
normalement l'eau participe c'était
l'égalité le côté c'est un des deux
bassins d'irrigation qu'on a ça contient
quand même habituellement très très
grandes quantités d'eau parce que le
sent
la chaleur et le temps sec se font
particulièrement sentir à donne à ma
cause du microclimat mais la saison
s'annonce réduite aussi dans les autres
d'hergé on parle d'environ une baisse de
8 pour salses et sussargues c'est u 10
par rapport à notre moyen de 5 ans
c'est pas dramatique
la clé de la saison ce sera la mcintosh
la variété la plus cultivée au québec il
faut qu'il fasse froid la nuit puis
soleil le jour pour que la pomme prenne
son rouge pour l'instant il nous reste
encore une semaine ou deux avant de
s'inquiéter vraiment là
mais dans tous les cas les pommes seront
prêtes plus tôt ce qui est compliqué
parce que des travailleurs étrangers ne
sont souvent pas encore disponibles et
les visiteurs n'ont pas encore la tête
aux pommes cette année c'est très lent
parce qu'il fait trop chaud les gens
sortent pas il reste son talent
absolument c'est normalement un drop
hommes mais c'est plutôt en plus c'est
beaucoup de semaine plus tôt si on peut
avoir des belles journées fraîches
ensoleillé le 15 août et fait le yoyo
faune les arbres devraient quand même
être bien chargé pour les autos
cueilleurs à condition qu'ils devancent
un peu leur sortie cette année il se
marie claude morin radio-canada à donnât